I take two more
you get all the perspective the best you
can do outside of traveling here you get
here and suddenly you're in the midst of
a busy refugee camp all the cameras are
sync together and there are 24 of them
and it records simultaneously in full
360 also 3d it is so simple you just use
your phone and you can see this
360-degree 3d moving image it really
really takes you that you feel like you
are in the scene you look around you and
you feel like you're looking at it with
your own eyes
you're thinking from the refugees
standpoint it feels like you're there so
this just goes in there like that
yep who's your ice and move around feel
like you're worth there
when we're filming in here and place
like this normally it's very 2d isn't it
you see exactly what the camera wants
you to see in that see it you know you
know we have a little desensitized who
you watch enough of it but the here that
you're you're here it's unflinching so
we've come down here with the jaunt and
we want to try and sort of capture the
atmosphere down here as it unfolds you
will create a much more experience of
experience and you can actually look
around and you will essentially be
transported to here you know as best you
can
you